also since we've been canceled because
normally all of our haters we don't pay
any attention to right we have no
interest in them we don't care but ever
since we've been canceled everyone's
sending us dirt on all of them right so
everyone's sending us you know like a
bunch of stuff that we can't say on air
because we're nice men like addresses
and stuff we're not gonna do that but um
uh videos of things they've said and all
this kind of crap so let's look at some
of the people who have turned on me
right some of the people who think i
should be canceled let's decide who's
the real danger to women if it's me or
if it's some of these individuals who
who are champion women's rights right
they're out here to protect women
supposedly to save them from from oh
[Music]
this is where it goes i'm such a bad guy
let's have a look let's have a look at
this guy some clips
oh
boy
ethan cline let's go
in this climate it's like you can't say
anything anymore i can't say anything
without tons of people getting triggered
and complaining nobody cares to listen
and understand everybody just hates each
other every more yeah it's almost like
people wish that some other people get
deleted for having a differing opinion
it's crazy nobody can express their
opinion anymore our apes or whatever
right our
neanderthal cousins were probably just
raping like crazy so there's definitely
something like
in us to like conquer men want to like
right so it's you know women are
in a nature setting like
to be conquered
i love that i can just say your thoughts
yeah like i couldn't i couldn't really
say that that was that was just like
hard r flat out
what are you gonna do doesn't trigger me
do we have any insight into what they're
actually talking about there at the nra
meeting that's today in texas someone
should bomb that building
i know he's just being sarcastic and
provocative he's not really calling for
terrorism i mean give me a break that's
another i'm not gonna let that tr this
should trigger me because it's also out
of context it doesn't show the breath of
who this guy is i've watched his show
not a ton but enough to know that he's
just sarcastic and he he really is
harmless so you know i know i know that
tate's just given him a taste of his own
medicine yeah that that's what it is
like he's giving him back exactly you
know we we don't need to but we see we
see both sides we think it's stupid both
ways we need to not become the evil that
we're trying to fight and it's hard it's
hard not to but we she said we need to
not be that
[Music]
we didn't call for a terrorist attack oh
god everybody calm down who's the danger
to the internet
this guy is calling for terrorist
attacks by youtube standards and all the
[ __ ] that they've said yeah he should
have been immediately canceled and wiped
off the internet and you know wiped off
the face of the earth but again he was
just being sarcastic so he's not really
a danger to anybody and if there's
someone on the other end of that screen
going ethan made me do it
like give me a give me a [ __ ] break
that's they're the problem that's a
lunatic we need to reopen the loony bins
and throw them in for rape say women are
just there to be conquered who the [ __ ]
is this guy this guy's a genuine
credible threat to women because on top
of it all he is objectively unattractive
just like we talked about earlier when
you look up any kind of sexual predator
they're unattractive people he's
objectively unattractive objectively out
of shape and he's clearly calling and
saying absolutely huh ted bundy was a
good looking guy who said bundy is yeah
the guy who killed like multiple girls
yeah just i guess he's just the
exception to the rule but yes typically
they are gross i didn't you know that
comments women are just out in nature to
be conquered didn't see context yeah
there's there what's the context there
he was talking about cave people and i
think that was true you know people
didn't have any social can you take
those glasses off
i just wanted to wear them because my
friend nolan left them in my car and i
sent him a picture with them on and then
he started complaining at me to give him
back those the ones the dog was wearing
earlier i think so yeah oh cool why is
youtube not panicking about him and then
he's gonna sit there and pretend he
cares about women the n word i am
respectful enough to everybody in
across the planet that although i am a
mixed-race individual i do not use the
n-word what the [ __ ] but you know what
that just goes to show and you know what
i think the thing about ethan is andrew
when you read his comments about yeah i
went to this nightclub and all the
security were black all the security
were black and that was that was weird
and then his wife was trying to pretend
that she didn't know so i was just
noticing they were wearing suits these
two racists are singing together saying
the n-word and talking about how how
unsafe they feel when the security are
black they see a man like you who is a
person of color cut out come up in the
world and try and tear you down without
racist with with allegations of crime
right how racist can you get this guy
has shown his true colors when i saw
these clips i was like ah
now it makes sense but they're clips
yeah i don't think ethan's racist either
the big thing is that he's he's just
changed so much i used to actually enjoy
his videos and now he's just become such
a puss i can't even watch him anymore
really what's changed what do you mean
he's been a plus he's just he's just a
hypocrite and all the stuff that he used
to say like for you can't say anything
without getting canceled then he's like
praying that tate get gets cancelled he
constantly calls tate a sex trafficker
says that he beats women like all the
allegations that were proven false and
he just keeps going with them when the
fresh and fit guys when they were trying
to get him on a podcast he's like well i
need to see your vax cards before you
come to the studio he's just a puss now
he's clearly a racist and he's trying to
heavily compensate because he's a
misogynist and a racist and because he's
dangerous to women he's like no that
guy's to danger don't worry about me the
mixed race protective well i'm not
buying any of this unless i see
everything that all those things in full
context that's all that's all there is
to it i mean he's not going to convince
me that ethan's a racist by quite a few
clips by doing the same exact thing that
he hates having done to him agreed never
never talked about raping women and
doesn't talk about running around
wanting to rape him like i do he's the
danger the guy that all the women
actually want to talk to he's the danger
for me i'm not and imagine in nature the
women would just be there to be
conquered
conquerors got your hand down your pants
conquered them
racist you ain't conquered [ __ ] i don't
mean they probably didn't i mean they
didn't even have language and fire like
i don't know i don't know we don't know
what went on back then there was no
youtube you ain't conquered
twinkies you see squirrels did you have
you ever googled squirrel
no you got it's nice what are you doing
looking that up somebody out told me
about it once look up squirrel rape
she's crazy in nature what about the
next guy look at this guy who [ __ ]
[ __ ] if they all had squirrels all had
smartphones they probably wouldn't do
that join the discord in my bio don't be
a petty [ __ ] don't be a petty ass go
follow me on instagram follow my mom on
instagram pop out you see pictures of my
dog let's do a unique outro song for
this one this is in memory of ethan
klein before he became a puss i meet
them bradberry
you